لا بد من حل اما بالاشعه ولا بالكيمياوي
الى القضاء على هذه الخلايا السرطانيه
الموجوده داخل المؤسسات الدوله
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم السلطات التونسيه تصدر
مذكرات اتهام بحق عدد من المعارضين
سياسيين بالانتباه لتنظيم ارهابي والتامر
على امن الدوله وفريق الدفاع يقول ان
الاتهامات جزء من حمله استهداف المعارضين
في حين اتهم الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد من
وصفهم بالماجورين من الخارج بمحاوله ضرب
امن الدوله
اضراب في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه حدادا
على الشهداء الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا في
نابلس وقوات الاحتلال تقصف مواقع للفصائل
الفلسطينيه في غزه بعد اطلاق سته صواريخ
على مستوطنات متاخمه للقطاع في وقت يبحث
فيه المبعوث الاممي جهود خفض التوتر وعدم
التصعيد تزامنا مع احتدام المعارك شرقيه
اوكرانيا مؤسس شركه فاغنر يؤكد استئناف مد
مقاتله بالذخيره بعد خلافات علنيه مع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بوتين قال روسيا
ستواصل دعم ثالوثها النووي واعطاء
الاولويه لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه بينما
رجحت بريطانيا استمرار الحرب عاما اخر
وكاله اللجوء الاوروبيه تعلن تسجيل اعلى
عدد من طلبات اللجوء منذ سته اعوان بزياده
نحو 50% مقارنه بالعام الماضي مرشحه ان
هذا الارتفاع ناجم جزئيا عن رفع قيود
جائحه كورونا فضلا عن النزاعات وانعدام
الامن الغذائي في العالم الى اللقاء